[Music]
[Applause]
remember when machine gun kelly posted
this picture of a necklace containing
megan fox's blood
it is really cool and ever since we've
been wondering
what the angelina jolie and billy bob
thornton is going on
it's his blood oh yeah but it is blunt
that's hard to top that one man well now
mgk is explaining how
this creepy yet romantic piece of
jewelry came to be in a recent interview
with ellen degeneres
well she was actually going out of town
to film a movie
and um this was really new in our
relationship i was
you know like i didn't have a passport
either so she was going out uh to
bulgaria
and so i was kind of freaking out like
oh you're gonna leave and i can't even
come see you or whatever so apparently
megan decided the best way to prove her
love was real was to cut herself
open and bleed for him i mean some
people give like a handkerchief to their
partner or whatever she gave me her dna
and the story gets even more out there
their long-distance relationship was
short-lived thanks to
none other than wait for it bernie
sanders
you know who helped me get a passport
bernie sanders
thank you so much i haven't even talked
to him since this happened thank you
thank you to the bernie sanders team
for that that you i made it to bulgaria
and wow
relationships going strong so thank you
so much fantastic
mgk whose real name is colson baker
didn't further explain how the senator
helped him
but we did get more answers about his
and megan fox's
relationship like what they were doing
jumping over a three-story building
i saw this roof and i was like i used to
hang up there like i just want you to
come
and see my world for a minute and uh
it was on a the door was locked so we
had to scaffold
around like the belt it was very
dangerous and it was your first date
first date but that wasn't as risky as
their second date
she loves nature she's like very in tune
with
the earth and i'm scared of sharks so we
went swimming with sharks
and it seems like coulson is not scared
of anything even megan's
new house which they think is haunted i
had a a weapon
to make sure that everyone was safe and
so i went through the house
with the weapon to shoot a ghost the
couple has been going strong
since they were first linked in june of
last year
[Applause]
in april they celebrated his 31st
birthday with
oh you know this other hot couple
kourtney kardashian and travis
barker i love it last month the source
told
et that mgk and megan are very in love
i don't want to lose that feeling he
always puts megan first
treats her like a queen and is super
respectful thoughtful and funny which
are all the qualities that she loves